hi guys i've got a little trick for you
today we're going to play a game called
maze runner and it is probably one of
the worst games ever made
because i made it i did a course in
college it was a game design and i made
this in six weeks
i haven't played it since i made it so
let's see how it is
basically it's based all around a book
called maze runner
where this guy comes to a place called
the glade
can't remember how he got there and he
has to go around a maze
trying to be eaten by these creatures so
i thought that'd make a really good
scary game so this is the glade
oh bless me old me
i remember i was so happy with these
blinds because i just put
spotlights behind them and it made them
look all creepy and
eerie or so i thought
kind kind of works welcome to the glade
your only goal is to escape
okay yasmine i shall escape
so this was like supposed to be one of
the houses
in the glade where he wakes up because
the glade is just a place in the middle
of a maze
uh oh yeah this is all my boring college
stuff so i just had to write about
the target audience so males age 15 to
25 should like this game
apparently are you a male 15 to 25
um oh it doesn't say about females i'm
so sexist
oh yeah
oh my gosh it's a static tv
i was so tough for myself with that idea
this is like the biggest sofa
i've ever seen in my entire life oh
there's females secondary target
audience ah okay i'm not sexist
dude sexist from my own gender
say goodbye to the giants over goodbye
giant silver
uh this is just like similar games
supposed to be the bedroom
so this game was based on slender
obviously
you remember when slender was really big
and everyone loved it and wanted to play
all the time yeah that was
around that time that i made this uh
what else was it based on i think it was
based on uh
amnesia yes amnesia
so it's supposed to be like a horror
strategy game
dark and eerie props simple old and born
dark that doesn't make sense yasmine
game is based on the book
which sold so well it's a really good
book actually i think you should all
have a little look at it doesn't you
violence kill monsters and severalizing
strategy right yeah so
that's why it's like amnesia because you
don't get
anything to kill the monsters
marketing awareness ah this is cool
imagine how much fun i had making this
game right whenever i was testing it i'd
just come in and just
have a little boogie at like four in the
morning
this is the kitchen can i dance on the
table
come on
uh yeah just how i would promote the
game
so here here you can have a look at my
really terrible
animation you've got to collect a
flashlight which will help you
look through the maze so you pick up the
flashlight
and then you go to the door but i've
emanate animated it to get open the
wrong way and then it's just like sky
so you just walk out into the sky
oh dear it's so terrible oh my god
this is darker than i remember it being
so i put glow sticks to help people
remember the way
which is quite nice to me i think
oh oh that's my torch what is that
okay so you press f to turn the torch on
or the game would just be unplayable
just tell you somewhere
i probably missed
oh here it go press f to toggle your
flashlight
i was so excited that was the first part
uh the first bit of proper unity script
i'd ever made
just turning on and off the flashlight
and i was like yes
it's so clever
um which way i go so this way
looks like a dead end there'll be plenty
of these damn it
oh oh my geez okay so that's one of the
monsters that i put in there
is this the right way i think this is
the dead end as well my eyes so confused
i've lost my way already this is my game
and i lost my way
okay these pickle bushes look sharp
better keep it out of the way
so this is supposed to be a prickle bush
no comment
wait where's my health it's supposed to
be 100 right now
okay well that's everybody oh well i'll
fix that later
okay i'm back i've just made some
changes now you can see the health
it's a bit farther down than i thought
it was gonna be but
meh it's better than nothing at least
you can see what my health is
and see if i go into this oh i get hurt
so creative and unique
not
okay so if i remember i think it's up
this way
phone you could sos oh look at the moon
that's nice
okay oh let's go so it says
beware of the groovers who live in this
maze there is no way of attacking them
so if you see one
don't hesitate to run and if i
yeah yeah
let's just show you but i don't know can
i oh gosh
okay that's what i did like
luckily we're both slow
unfortunately i don't have a running
mechanism maybe i should put one in
do you like my rocks they took my cages
okay so
this way oh god i hope i've lost him
all right so this way because that's
where the glow stick was
glow stick it's down here
i'm scared i'm scared for my own game
this is good
and when i first played it i showed it
to my mates
in college one of them actually screamed
and jumped
yes got you oh i put in an easter egg
if i can find it somewhere around here
what's going on but it's time you know
the truth
look at the texture on it everything's
terrible
everything's going to change oh
oh gosh oh freaked out now
okay so that was my little easter egg
this guy trying to get
in touch with you telling you that
everything's going to change
because that's actually one of the lines
in the book as well oh my giddy hard
okay you see he touched me my health i
down by
30.
if i could do this again i would
probably put a little noise in there to
let you know
he's gone good oh by the way
you're just trying to find a key in the
maze
uh because there's a door at the end
that you need to open up
which way oh not that way
nope not that way i'm nearing the end
so it's going to be hard
50 health though not bad
did i go through that did i go through
that
oh my gosh you see
oh well oh hello goodbye
oh that's so creepy oh okay
blue one that's good
no
oh can you hear it where's the key
here it is the key
to the exit is missing you cannot leave
without it must be hidden somewhere
within the maze
oh jeez okay
right right so that was that was the
ending
and now i need to find the key and i do
kind of remember where it is
but it gets really confusing around here
i don't know i think it's this way is it
oh this is a dead end
hello i think it is this way
purple i haven't seen a purple one yet
don't think
here it is yes i was totally right
now you get the spinning key oh ah
did i get it yes i got it okay let's go
uh just to stop making silly faces that
you
concentrate
okay so i've got the key
and now i just gotta go past this guy
oh he's so creepy oh it's okay he only
had me once
ah hello moon
this is the biggest door ever the door
seemed to have led
nowhere as you plummeted further into
the abyss not knowing what could be at
the bottom you found yourself wondering
whether the glade was such a bad place
after all so that was the end what do
you think
did did you like it i know it's not the
best thing ever i just wanted to show
you what you can do with unity because
unity is free and anyone can do it
which before i did my six week course of
games
design i knew nothing about game
development
i knew nothing about design i knew
nothing about coding
and i made this in six weeks and it just
shows what you can do so if you
are interested in anything like this
just download unity all the smoke and
everything that was already in unity and
you can use blender to make your own 3d
models
or you can find them on places like
turbo squid i'll leave all the links in
the description
where you can find stuff that will help
you make games let me know what you
thought of my game
i knew it wasn't amazing but i'm kind of
proud of it for my first ever game give
us a thumbs up if you liked my game and
have a lovely day out evening bye
i can tell from the music it just
reminds me playing monkey island all
over again
love it shoes massive shoes
all right this is inventory okay then
glass and bread oh oh
why did i do that such an idiot